in ukraine the russian military is
shelling areas near the capital where
they had promised to scale back fighting
ukraine's president told his people last
night that the effort to repel russia's
invasion has reached a turning point the
ukrainians say they have pushed back
russian tank units in several areas the
white house said yesterday that russian
officials may be afraid to tell
president vladimir putin how badly the
war effort is doing holly williams is
near the southern city of her son
here is the evidence that russia's
invasion has stalled in parts of ukraine
a burned-out russian armored personnel
carrier that ukrainian forces say they
destroyed just four days ago
we traveled with a convoy of ukrainian
soldiers yesterday volunteers from all
walks of life heading to reinforce the
front line they attacked our home andrei
rogalski was a crane operator until he
signed up earlier this month he's had
just two weeks basic training and told
us he's frightened he could be killed
but said he and the others here have
defeated those fears because they know
what they're fighting for it's for evil
pure evil exactly
he's talking about this
russian attacks on hospitals apartment
buildings and civilians
the u.s says it's seen clear evidence
that vladimir putin's forces are
committing war crimes
in the besieged city of mariopol alone
the united nations says thousands of
civilians may have been killed
but russia is also taking heavy losses
in the face of a ukrainian resistance
much tougher than many expected
seven to fifteen thousand russian troops
have been killed in around a month
according to a nato official in
comparison in 20 years of war in
afghanistan the u.s lost fewer than 2
500.
andrei ragowski believes vladimir putin
is a tragedy for both ukrainians and
russians
he's
second lieutenant tatiana chornaval has
frontline experience of russia's
military capabilities she's a former
politician and mother of two who's now
tasked with taking out russian tanks she
told us this was one of her hits
the russians are fighting stupidly she
said they don't have a strategy or
tactics they're falling into the same
traps and their commanders are just
pushing them to advance
a british intelligence chief said today
that the russians have weapon shortages
and have even accidentally shot down
their own aircraft but ironically he
said that vladimir putin has succeeded
in making nato more united than before
gail
holly williams reporting from ukraine
thank you